I actually get very addicted whenever I
start studying chess which is why I
don't do it as seriously when I'm
focused on content because I go through
these rabbit holes where if I'm focusing
on chess I want to be as good as I
possibly can at the game otherwise it's
hard for me to enjoy it because it's
such a competitive thing and I remember
training for tournaments and when you're
training for tournaments you even start
dreaming about Chess and you can't stop
thinking about it and it's as if you're
flipped into this completely different
world which is also what I like best
about the game that it's a completely
different living experience and then you
take some drugs and now you start to see
things on the ceiling is there some
factual
um hallucination like uh to the uh
Queen's Gambit like those scenes uh I
think it's is that based on your life
story from well I can't say that on
camera no just kidding
um actually chess players are very
careful to not take drugs they drink a
lot yeah they drink so much it's
actually crazy for how good they're able
to play chess when they do but when it
comes to things like psychedelics or
other things they usually stay away from
those because they don't want to mess
anything up in their brain so this is
actually intervention I've I saw that
you mentioned somewhere I think it was
the lie detector test where you have a
drinking problem
I think I think that's actually a meme
that we like to joke about on stream
because occasionally we'd have like a
white Claw on stream or something like
that and then people meme about it it
goes back to Andrea's point of
amplifying a part of your personality to
make yourself a little bit right more
entertaining I'm going to use that as an
excuse from now on I'm just this podcast
is just amplifying a part of that person
now I'm not really like this but have
you played drunk like Magnus let's play
drunk he says it helps someone with the
creativity is there any truth to that
well Andreas under 21 so she's obviously
would never do would never do that
um but I have played while drinking
actually
I enjoy playing Jess chess and drinking
more than pre-gaming or going out to a
club and drinking which sounds really
silly and I'll usually play against
opponents who are also you know having
some beer and it does make you feel like
you're seeing the game from a fresher
perspective where it can sometimes make
you feel more confident liquid
confidence and it does help with
creativity you just feel like you could
pull things off but there's also a limit
it's more like you've had one drink or
two drink but then it goes beyond that
and then you just start missing tactics
and it's not worth it yeah I think it
only helps players in very short time
controls one time I was challenging this
Grand Master on stream and we were
playing bullet chess which is one minute
chess and I was giving him handicaps and
I said okay you have to take four shots
before the next game and he just got
like 10 times stronger and transformed
into like the Hulk and destroyed me more
than last game so but of course if
you're playing like a three hour game
it's gonna get old but I think in short
time controls it's amazing yeah it does
definitely has to be blue it has to be
where it's more intuition rather than
sitting in calculations this is probably
like negatively affecting your ability
to calculate absolutely yeah